se abre paso entre la multitud aclamado
por sus soldados con armas en mano
al general en jefe del ejército sudanés
abdel fatal burham ha venido arengar a
sus tropas en las calles de jartum
mientras el día anterior La tregua en
vigor desde el 22 de mayo se prorrogó
cinco días sin ser respetada
no estamos utilizando la fuerza letal y
todavía no hemos recurrido a la fuerza
máxima
soldados estamos preparados no queremos
destruir el país pero si el enemigo no
obedece nos veremos obligados a utilizar
todas nuestras fuerzas
hace un mes y medio que lucha contra las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido a su ex mano
derecha
mohalo conocido como emetti todas las
treguas hasta ahora han seguido el mismo
camino con armas que nunca se silencian
en tierra continúan los ataques aéreos
al juego de artillería y los movimientos
de blindados particularmente en la
capital y en la región de darfur donde
los convoyes llenos de alimentos siguen
teniendo dificultades para pasar se han
registrado numerosos casos de
desnutrición aguda en el país uno de los
más pobres del mundo y según la ONU 25
millones de los 45 millones de sodaneses
ya no pueden sobrevivir sin ayuda
humanitaria esta lucha fratricida que
comenzó el 15 de abril entre dos
generales rivales ya se ha cobrado más
de 1800 vidas y casi un millón y medio
desplazados y refugiados